翻訳: Noriko Take
校正: Hiroko Kawano
皆さん こんにちは
（観客）こんにちは
今日は 皆さんの 皆さんの夢を
皆さんの夢を
壊すためにここに来ました
（笑）
音楽には 国境があります
1934年 日本で
偉大な方が亡くなりました
国は その方の死を悼み
国葬を執り行いました
そしてアメリカのNBC —
MBCじゃないですよ （笑）
ふるさとたっぷりの方じゃありませんから
アメリカのNBCが
追悼の気持ちを込めて
この音楽を流したのです
（音楽開始）
（音楽終了）
どうですか 皆さん？
これね 大変ふざけた音楽なんですよ
これは「かっぽれ」といいます
もともと 大阪の住吉大社 —
あの 漁業関係の人が
よく信仰する神社ですけれども —
そこで踊られていた
｢住吉踊り｣というものが元になっています
それを｢豊年斎梅坊主｣ —
面白い名前ですね —
豊年斎梅坊主という大道芸人が
明治の時にですね
日本全国に広めました
で どこでこれが歌われていたか
踊られていたかというと
まず寄席
僕の大好きな三代目古今亭志ん朝が
よく踊っていました
それは面白おかしく
座を盛り上げるためにですよ
そして 芸者さんが酒宴
つまりお酒を飲む席で
お客さんを楽しませるために
面白おかしく
ふざけて踊ったものなのです
さて この曲を贈られた人物
この方は
この方です
皆さんよくご存じの 東郷平八郎
はい 鹿児島にゆかり深いですよね
どういうことが起こったかというと
国民は大変憤慨しました
怒りました
外務省も抗議しましたよ
NBCに｢けしからん｣と
こんな音楽をこんな偉大な方のための
葬式のために流して
もうとんでもないことだと
なぜこんなことが起こったのでしょうか？
NBCは全く悪意は無かったのです
持っていた日本の音楽の
複数の日本の音楽の中から
この｢かっぽれ｣が良いと思って
良かれと思って選んだんですよ
なぜかというと
音楽的な背景、文化的背景が
分からなかったために
こういう問題が起きたのです
音楽はですね
単なる音の連続ではありません
そこには 作った人のメッセージとか
時代のメッセージが込められています
その文化的背景が分からなかったために
こういう問題が起きたのです
次に
皆さんは 音楽は
喜怒哀楽を表すものと信じています
それは 愛や憎しみや
いろんな感情がありますよね
悲しみや そういうものをね
表すと信じています
しかし 世界には
感情が入らない音楽もあるのです
例えば 南インドの音楽には
人間の喜怒哀楽というような
はしたない感情は入っていません
まるで 宇宙的な客観的な大自然を表す
そういった音楽なのです
ちなみに 目をつぶって
ちょっと聴いてみましょう
（音楽開始）
（音楽終了）
ありがとうございました
目を開けたら 僕が宙に浮かんでたら
最高なんですけれども
（笑）
僕もこの音楽 あんまりわかりません
でもなんとなく
まぁ そういう雰囲気は感じられます
日本にも
喜怒哀楽が入らない音楽があります
それは 雅楽です
（音楽開始）
（音楽終了）
ありがとうございました
雅楽には 喜怒哀楽が必要ないんです
なぜなら 千三百年前から
雅楽は続いていますが
宮廷の儀式用の音楽であって
喜怒哀楽は必要ないんですね
儀式が厳かに執り行われることが目的であって
そこに感情は必要ないんです
もう一つ面白い話をします
これも文化的なことなんですけれども
雅楽は千三百年前から今まで
ほとんど形を変えないで
演奏され続けてきました
それはですね 面白いルールがあるんです
｢他管に物を申さず｣
｢かん｣というのは｢管｣です
まあ 簡単に言いますと
他の楽器に注文をつけちゃ
いけないということです
僕の仕事と反対です
僕はいつも楽器に注文つけてます
｢あーすいません そこのフルートの人
ちょっと速すぎるので
遅くしてください｣とか
｢あ すいません
トランペット大きすぎます
こっちのチェロが聞こえませんから
もうちょっと柔らかくやってください｣
なんてことは絶対にしてはいけません
僕の仕事とは反対です
どういうことをするかというと
一つ一つの楽器に
一つ一つのファミリーがついてるんですね
一つのファミリーが 一つの楽器を
ずーっと継承して演奏しています
ということは
おじいさんからお父さん
お父さんから子供
子供から孫とか
まあそうですね
演奏の方法を忠実に守ることが
一番大事なのです
あの音楽 合ってると思いますか?
我々の感覚から言うと
まあ合ってるとも言えるけど
合ってないとも言えるけど
よくわかんないとこですよね
それは同時進行してるから
お互いのルールが同時進行していって
あの 笙の人がお琴の人にね
｢ちょっと大きすぎるんじゃない｣って
絶対言っちゃいけません
それは 日本の古来から続いている
｢和をもって尊し｣という世界なんですね
ですから 千三百年も続けられてきたんです
次
世界で一番 民主的な音楽を聴きましょう
（音楽開始）
（音楽終了）
ありがとうございます
ジャズです
まあ 全部聴けば
よくわかるんですけど
ジャズは世界で一番民主的な音楽です
例えば ４人いたとします
サックス､ドラム､ピアノ､ベース
それぞれが 自分の意見を
主張する場があります
インプロビゼーション
即興演奏という形でですね
ですから その文化的背景は
アメリカで育った
ということがよくわかります
そうですよね
民主主義を大事にしてますから
なるほどジャズは
そういうところで育ったんだなと
僕はそう思います
このように 世界には様々な音楽があり
その文化的背景を知れば
より深く音楽を理解することができます
逆に言えば 最初の問題のように
文化的背景が分からないと
全く音楽が分からない
そういうことにもなります
1982年 僕は
一つのリュックサックを持って
ヨーロッパを一人で旅行しました
なんと２ヶ月です
ヨーロッパ中歩きました
ま ずっと歩いたわけじゃないですよ
電車で行って歩いている
いろんな街を —
まあ 誤解しないでください ー
そこでですね
日本には 一流の音楽家が
たくさん来るでしょう？
だから音楽は聴けるんですね
でもそこの風土が
僕は知りたかったんです
育ったところの空気や人々とか
まあ 教会の壁を触ってみたりですね
石畳に 寝そべってみたりもしました
体感したかったわけですよね
そういう育った文化的土壌を 知りたかった
一番最初に印象に残ったのは
ポーランドです
ポーランドの舞踊学校を訪れて
ノックしてですね ガラッと開けて
｢すいません 僕は日本から来ました
音楽を勉強しています
ポーランドの代表的な
マズルカを踊ってください｣
これ大変なことなんですよ 皆さん
1982年 ポーランドは共産主義ですよ
そこに自由主義からの青年が
ガラッと入ってきてですね
いきなり｢踊ってください｣なんて
ありえない話ですよ 本当は
かなり危険です コンタクトするだけでも
でも先生はすごく良い人で
バレリーナを集めて
なんとマズルカを踊ってもらいました
そこで
そしてですね
｢あなたも一緒に踊りましょう｣と言われて
僕も踊ったんですよ
その時の光景 見たいですか？
見たいですよね
これです
（笑）
大変だったんですよ
マズルカっていうのは
もうクルクルクルクル回るんですね
そんなことも知らずにね
｢自分も踊ってみたい｣なんて
言っちゃったんですね
それがこの絵です
次に印象に残ったのは スペインです
スペインで一番印象に残ったのは
セビリアでした
なぜならセビリアを舞台とした音楽が
たくさんあるからです
モーツァルト作曲
オペラ『ドン・ジョヴァンニ』
セビリアです
そしてロッシーニ作曲
オペラ『セビリアの理髪師』
もうこれはもろですね これは
もう入っています
もう一つ言いましょうか？
ビゼー作曲 オペラ『カルメン』
だからですね
僕はセビリアを歩き回りましたから
すごく勉強になりました
僕は『カルメン』を指揮するときは
もうバッチリですね
ええ 文化的背景はもう入ってますから
昼は 闘牛に通ってですよ
夜は フラメンコです
フラメンコに毎晩通いました
フラメンコダンサーが感激してくれて
持ってる帽子もらったんですよ
闘牛士の役の時の
その時の様子 見たいですか?
（笑）
すいません それはありません （笑）
先に行きます
一番最近 印象に残ったのは ギリシャです
ギリシャでは ペロポネソス半島という
昔から行きたかったところに行きました
どんな街があるかというと
ミケーネ､スパルタ､オリンピア
そういうところがあります
ギリシャは ヨーロッパ文化の
元になってるところですから
それにギリシャの劇を
主題にした音楽がたくさんあります
『エディプス王』とかですね
いろいろあります
ギリシャ神話を元にした音楽も
たくさんあります
ですから ギリシャに行ってきました
オリンピアも印象に残っています
これは オリンピアの
古代オリンピック劇場で走る僕の雄姿です
（笑）
実際走ってきましたよ 本当に
全力疾走でこの後 走ってるんです
国は違いますが
キプロスという国があります
キプロス島というのがありまして
そこには ヴィーナスが
流れ着いたという海岸があります
そこにも行ってきました
ヴィーナスには会えませんでした
ここに 流れ着いたんですね
ボッティチェリの絵がありますね
『ヴィーナスの誕生』
あれもこういう イメージじゃないですかね
このように 様々な地を訪れることによって
その文化的背景を知ることが
自分の仕事に
ものすごくプラスになっています
皆さんも 大好きな音楽があったら
その背景にある文化的な背景を
調べてみてください
まあ 可能であったら
行ってみてください
そうすると その音楽が
より自分に近く感じることができるし
その音楽を
より深く感じることができます
最後にもう一回申し上げます
音楽には 国境があります
ありがとうございました
（拍手）